Congrats to the Baltimore Ravens,
you guys suck,
but you want a coffee or a Tuesday and
Vlog 48.
So when I finished the sixth grade and
was ready to make the big move,
did junior high.
My parents said,
you know,
Evan,
elementary school was easy,
but next year junior high,
it's not going to be so easy.
Next year is going to be hot,
so I steeled my 11 year old self and
brace for junior high with a certain
figure and expectation that life has so
far been a light breeze,
but now that was over there was going to
be a certain fundamental change and
things in that change would be for the
worse.
Well,
seventh grade came in,
seventh grade went and when I opened my
eyes,
everything was still pretty simple and
pretty easy.
Things really hadn't changed that
summer.
My parents said,
you know,
Evan,
seventh grade was easy,
but eighth grade,
whoa,
things are going to get serious now.
Get ready.
Eighth grade came and went that summer.
My parents warned me about high school,
but by that time I had come to believe
that they were pretty unreliable sources
in this particular field.
Nonetheless,
they kept saying so every year through
high school and college and every year I
couldn't help but almost believed them,
but every year they were wrong.
Now,
to be very clear,
I am not implying in any way that I'm
gifted or smarter than the average
person.
The whole point of the nerd writer is
that I'm not,
but I never did do much work in school.
I never did try very hard.
I found despite my parents' warnings,
that I didn't need to.
I often joke with friends that in school
I studied the teachers and not the
subjects and it's true.
If I deconstructed the personalities of
the great givers of how they were to
test and awarded points,
I could construct my own personality and
word my own answers in a way that was
complimentary and that's how I got
through.
I think I saw even at a young age that
reality was fluid.
It was in constant,
which made it flexible.
A huge number of the rules of society
were convention.
They were as alterable as people were
persuadable at the risk of self
psychoanalysis.
I think this comes in large part from my
dad who is in a word in cordial.
He's a born Hagler,
unwilling to believe that something
can't be done until these strided
himself.
It's a great quality,
but enough about me.
Is this just all in my head or is there
some truth to this id?
Well,
in the end,
what we're really talking about is
evolution.
We're talking about intuition,
reason morality.
We're talking about the way people were
early in Plato's Republic,
a dialogue about justice and the perfect
society.
The precocious young glaucon puts a
question to socrates worded in the
popular,
would you rather style it's this?
Would you rather be an honest and fair
person and have everyone believe that
you're a liar and the Douche bag,
or would you rather be a liar and a
douchebag and have everyone believed
that you're a fair and honest and
wonderful person?
Now it's Plato's prerogative to prove to
glaucon that being good is better than
seeming good.
That our minds are perfect reasoning
machines meant to find truth and master
the lowly passions despite the
reputational costs,
and that in truth is happiness.
Glaucon like a good little bitch is
eventually brought around,
but to be fair,
socrates is a master debater and what
he's saying sounds good,
but the reality of humanity is somewhat
different than Plato's idea of the truth
about us is that our minds are less
equipped for reasoning than they are for
justification.
A number of studies by moral
psychologist Robert Howard Margolis and
Jonathan Haidt show us that intuitions
and emotions rule that when in contact
with anything we react instantaneously
for or against that thing,
and our reason goes to work,
looking not for the truth,
but for a way to justify what we've
already decided.
Ever try telling someone they're wrong
about something flat out well.
Your tone has already defeated.
Your purpose of that person senses
confrontation.
Their whole being will turn away from
you,
the smart little politician in their
head.
The reason that Plato imagines is
working to find the truth instead goes
to work.
Finding the reasons why your wrong.
We've evolved to become outstandingly
adept at justifying our intuitions and
it explains a lot why we argue when
we're wrong,
why we forgive good looking people their
flaws and vice versa,
why we lie and omit and carefully carved
the versions of ourselves that we show
to others.
Simply the evolutionary advantages of
discovering the truth are less than the
evolutionary advantages of having a good
reputation glaucon,
who in the end would rather be a liar
that everyone likes has got us pinned
more accurately than even the great
plato.
To know these things gives one a great
power.
You're likely to get more out of life if
like my dad,
you haggle with reality,
addressing someone's intuitions or
emotions will more readily yield the
results that you want from them.
People are fluid.
Reality is people.
Reality is fluid.
There is an insidious side to this and I
think you could hear it.
Essentially,
we are made to be manipulated and
there's no shortage of that.
Of course,
in human history,
probably in your personal history too,
but along with our intuitive desire to
get what we want,
we are also guided by the intuitive
aversion to harm our reasoning.
Faculty is not a slave to our emotions,
but a politician and the best
politicians like the best people can
navigate a fluid reality of flexible
rules seeking,
ever subtler ways not to harm the people
they share the world with.
And you know what harms people
manipulation.
Hey everybody,
thanks for watching.
Don't forget to follow me on twitter and
tumbler links in the description.
Also,
if you want to read more about moral
psychology,
I highly recommend the righteous mind by
Jonathan Haidt is,
it's a great book,
extremely well written,
uh,
and you'll learn a little bit more about
why we think the way we think.
Um,
so read that and I will see you next
time.